okay uh i'll be on
great so
hello everyone
good to see you all here despite the
restrictions great to see uh quite a few
of you come along here
um they've given this talk twice before
once online and i did manage to give it
in person at
nbc tech town over in kongsberg
a couple of months ago and i have to say
it does work so much nicer in person so
uh so good to see you all here thanks
for coming
so welcome to solid revisited
and we will revisit that title
as we go go through the material of
course so i'm phil nash developer
advocate at sonar source
uh if you've seen it in my talks before
you may have seen uh a jet brains logo
up there before but i'm now at soda
sauce so uh
i've got the t-shirt as well just to
emphasize that
so
solid revisited the state of the matter
uh what are we talking about here
obviously the solid principles um who's
heard of the solid principles
so
just about everyone that's uh that's a
good start but who can actually tell me
uh what they all are
i'm not going to ask you to recite them
but uh who thinks they know them all
and of those few people that said that
who thinks they really know what they
all mean
[Laughter]
so this is a set of principles design
principles that we're meant to sort of
take quite seriously and follow
um in our development and yet nobody in
this room that was interested in the
solid principles and came here actually
knows what they are unless of course you
thought this was an introduction to the
solid principles um in which case
maybe there's still time to revisit that
decision
actually if you don't know what they are
uh you hopefully will learn quite a bit
about them
although i'm not gonna use the
traditional approach of going through
them one by one and and discussing them
it's gonna be more about tearing them
down and rebuilding them and they're
seeing what's what's behind them and
also a little bit of a history behind
them
now i i didn't actually set out to to
write this talk originally
it sort of evolved uh after some ideas
i'd been i'd have kicking around i do a
tdd training course where i talk about
the solid principles and i realize that
i really talk about them i sort of talk
around them
and i reference a talk by kevin henney
uh solid lead construction which he did
at this conference a few years ago which
is a great talk but we'll actually
discuss it a bit more later as well do a
bit of a meta review
um
there'll be references to all of the
additional material that i'm going to
mention through the talk by the way
at the end i'll give you a single link
you can follow so you can you can find
that talk easily and a few other talks
as well
um so yeah as part of that material i do
my tdd training i thought i'm not really
doing it justice
so finally i decided to
put this material together but i first
did it as a more of an interactive thing
at the extreme tuesday club in london
um earlier in the year and i managed to
get kevin henny
and dan north who is
another talk that we're going to talk
about
um it's part of this material they both
came along so we had quite a discussion
about it so i've got extra material to
go in so
that's really what this is all about so
maybe become clear as we go through but
let's start with that history
um
if you weren't too sure about the solid
principles and you did a google search
just to find out you know where should i
get started
you might hit this blog post
by uh by bob martin
aka uncle bob sure we've all heard of
bob martin um obviously
the one who put the solid principles
together although some nuances there
we'll get to that
so 2009
this game that's a little while ago now
um
but you know he does say i'm often asked
ask how should i get started with the
solid principles
uh so that seems to be the right place
to start
but then in that first things first
section
he says you can read about the solid
principles here
it gives a link great let's follow that
and unfortunately it takes you to to
this site
which is a choose vacation rentals
unfortunately he he no longer is in
control of the object mentor
um domain name it's been link jacked in
fact most of the links in the article
now
resolve here so not so useful of course
we have a solution to that the wayback
machine so
we can find what he was referring to it
says design principles and design
patterns
paper
uh from uh from about 20 years ago now a
couple of decades
um
and
it's quite a long paper actually it's an
interesting read
so it's got as i said principles and
patterns put some side by side
so just picking up the principles that
he talks about and we're just going to
use the three-letter acronym acronyms
for now we'll get to the
names later these are the principles
that he talks about
so you might recognize some of them but
there's a few more
if we wanted to follow these we might
say that we're following the
old dica cast principles which doesn't
quite roll off the tongue
as well um
which
yeah might be just a throwaway uh joke
but actually there's a serious point
behind that
looking at the first four
okay maybe we can get the oldie
principles that's a little bit more
promising they are getting quite old now
but
yeah these are part of what we now think
of of the solid principles
it's only a bit later that he added srp
to that list
to get well the the salty principles
it's still not quite there
but forward a couple of years 2003
beginning of
bob martin released this book agile
software development
principles patterns and practices
and
in well from chapter seven what is agile
design he then introduces
this set of principles
notice still in the order soldie
so
we haven't actually got the solid
principles yet we've got the extra
principles themselves
but not that acronym
2005 so a couple years later again
bob martin
writes the principles of ood
or principles of ood
and
you notice at the bottom there
we've got those principles listed in now
the order of solid
there's two
matter of a bit easier to read
still blurring out the the actual
names for now in fact he then goes on to
talk about those other principles as
well from from the earlier paper
interestingly in that whole article he
never once
says the solid principles so he's got
them in the right order but not
not by name yet what happened in the
meantime though
was it had a conversation with michael
feathers
uh neither of them could remember
exactly when it was so i can't pinpoint
that but sometime between 2003 2005
feathers said you know if you just
change those last two around you've got
a nice acronym there
uh this is the first that i could find
he actually put them in that order
sometime after that
he started talking about the solid
principles
so we've got a bit of a timeline
all these things we just talked about
from 2000 to
2005 and on um but there's also a little
bit of a pre-history here
because while we credit bob martin with
the solid principles he didn't actually
come up with the underlying ideas at
least not all of them
we actually have to go back as far as
the 70s
for that
79 tom demarco
wrote a structured analysis and system
specification
and a
big section there is about cohesion
which forms the basis of srp we'll talk
about that a bit later
1988 bertrand mayor object-oriented
software construction
we get the the open closed principle
from that we'll talk about that
later as well
also in 1988 barbara liskoff
data abstractions and hierarchy
and we get the the well she didn't call
it the list of substitution principle
but
that's where we get that from
um and then in the mid-90s
robert martin himself wrote a series of
uh papers for the subplus plus report
where
he he picked some of those ideas and
added a few of his own and that between
all of those that's where we get
those five principles are you notice
they even come in more or less in
chronological order
so that was that was quite nice
and the rest as they say
is history
we will actually come back to some of
these
these uh this historical context a bit
later so it's not just as an interesting
aside
but
let's actually look at the principles
themselves
so
not many of you actually said you knew
what the names were so i'm not going to
get you to call them out but we'll just
very quickly sketch them in
so srp is the single responsibility
principle
and it's probably the most important one
in fact many of the other principles are
derivations of this one way or another
and in terms of how
the principles interact with things like
tdd and just good design in general
everything generally comes back to this
uh the open close principle why i
mentioned that by name
from
bertram mayer
but you know we say it's
things are open to extension but closed
to modification
still some digging we need to do there
though
we also mentioned the list of
substitution principle
interface segregation principle
you can think of as
basically the single responsibility
principle but applied at the level of
the interface
and the dependency inversion in
principle
um best known for being confused with uh
dependency injection
i find myself saying the dependency
injection principle sometimes there's a
relation there but they're not the same
thing
okay
so they're the principles
so we're not gonna dig too much into
each one um on their own merits but we
will sort of peel them apart a bit
i mentioned a couple of talks that
uh have actually um tried to tear them
down rebuild them um i particularly
mentioned this one
kevin henny's solid deconstruction so
here he's doing it at ndc london another
ndc
event
um anyone here seen this talk already
yeah well you've got some watching to do
it's a great talk
and we'll dig into a little bit more but
the other one
dan north's
why every single element of solid is
wrong
it was a lightning talk so you can give
him a little bit of uh
sort of emphasis there there
unfortunately this one i don't think
there's a recording of it online but you
can find the slides but that's mostly
what you need to know
now both of these
they've also proposed their own
acronyms for a set of principles
maybe slightly light-heartedly maybe
more seriously depending on how much
i've had to drink when you ask them
kevin proposes the the fluid principles
and we'll we'll look at those a little
bit later obviously a play on on solid
when when i did that xtc event with uh
kevin and dan
um dan said that he'd been working on
his own set of principles and he wasn't
quite ready to announce it yet but since
then he has he's written a blog post on
it which i'll give you a link to so he's
proposing the cupid principles
and he's a little bit more serious about
this
so that's worth looking up so we're
digging to the references there we're
not going to go into that one
too much
but
let's start with
what his lightning talk was about
he does a lot of this so he's talking
about the single responsibility
principle he says it's the pointlessly
vague principle
and this really gets to the heart of uh
the big the biggest problem with this
one the principle itself is fine it's
actually the the most important one
it's the naming
i mean he says it's pointlessly vague
maybe that's over the top but it is hard
to really get to the meaning of the
single responsibility principle what is
a responsibility
why can we only have one
what if two responsibilities belong
together
lots of questions that need to be
resolved it's it's hard to actually do
something with it even if you can
sort of intuitively get what the idea is
behind it
um
not there we go then what happened there
so
he proposes instead
write simple code
okay that makes sense you could argue
that's also a bit vague
but actually i think he's onto something
here we're gonna come back to that
topic a little bit later as well
i do like this expression at the end
though
refactor until it fits in your head
this is one of dan's favorite phrases he
uses it a lot and i think it's
typical dan north
sort of practical pragmatic insight
if something can fit in your head then
it's simple enough and if it can't well
you need to refactor until it does
that's actually an actionable principle
there so
i really like that
but in fact this idea of writing simple
code turns out to be his answer to all
of them
so
as i said i think he's actually on to to
something there we'll we'll touch on
that a bit later
let's have a look at kevin's talk
so
go through this one by one
kevin says that the single
responsibility principle is really just
tom demarco's idea of cohesion that
things that belong together should be
together
but things that don't belong together of
course shouldn't
and
kevin adds in this idea of adhesion as
being the the opposite so
yeah things are stuck together but
really they shouldn't be together there
are adhesives and it's a nice concept
too to keep in mind when you see that in
code that's adhesive code
gives you a name for it
um separation of concerns is another way
of of talking about it which is
maybe slightly better than single
responsibility um
it gets more to the heart of what it's
actually about but cohesion is really
the core concept so it's a shame that it
got renamed to something that was
less useful
ocp
i think you could summarize kevlin's
view as
well it just means use polymorphism
um but also separately
don't publish interfaces
prematurely and what it means by that is
that the part of the open closed
principle that the closed part closed
for modification
that feels a bit dated
rooted in in the 80s when it was
expensive to uh to change code and to
track it we didn't really have version
control systems um we did that but they
weren't widely used
so yeah we had to be very careful about
how we modified code um now of course
you know we should be feel free
to change our code easily that's a
that's a big part of this being able to
to change embracing change
but as soon as you've published an
interface to something outside of your
project or team
maybe even outside your your company as
soon as somebody else is relying on it
now you've got a contract with them and
at that point you are locked in at least
at the interface level so don't do that
too soon it's just the advice that he
summarizes from that
so okay that's maybe not the takeaway
most people get from the open close
principle so that's that's interesting
and then the lisk of substitution
principle perhaps the
most misunderstood of them all
again he summarizes it really as
use polymorphism again
but carefully
and really what
he meant by that
and i think this only really came out in
the discussion xtc was that
the list of substitution principles the
bit that most people misunderstand is
that it's really about contracts again
if you have a contract
on your interface
um
you know guaranteeing what the behavior
is that contract must be preserved
across polymorphism
so
something can do something different as
long as it obeys the same contract you
get the same guarantees
post conditions preconditions that's the
sort of contracts we're talking about
not normally in the discussion of the
list of substitution principle but
that's really
what it's about
so that was quite insightful level
isp
just single responsibility principle for
interfaces so he claims that's a bit
redundant do we actually need a whole
separate principle for that
tend to agree
and the dependency injection i did it
again the dependency inversion principle
it's really again use polymorphism
um specifically you know with interfaces
rather than implementation
inheritance specifically so
there you can see some common themes
there there's a lot of
the same thing being repeated so in fact
you can you can regroup them
and you get some sort of a graph like
this
got three three main areas
um the cohesion part
separation of concerns is quite central
and using
polymorphism with interfaces
do it carefully you know
respect contracts
and extra bit on the end don't publish
prematurely which is good advice
i'm not sure it really qualifies as a
like a central principle that we should
be following so really just boils down
to those two things
and cohesion with polymorphism
you can summarize the whole of the solid
principles as being about
so
that that really summarizes kevin's talk
um there's a lot more to it and lots of
extra bits of history and insight so
it's definitely well worth watching but
this is my main takeaway
he has a lot of good points and uh as
kevin always does interesting asides but
i don't necessarily
agree with everything he said
and in fact at the end of the talk and
we'll see if this audio works
uh is that gonna work
um maybe you didn't agree with
everything in fact probably did agree
with everything you weren't listening
your day didn't work but
hopefully you read that so yeah
kevin's talks
are not designed to do thinking for you
they're designed to make you think
so he will say things that
um he doesn't expect you to agree with
but if he gets you thinking then
that's his job done and this is no no
exception
and i think
that points missed in a lot of the
criticism of this talk
so
he's not saying that solid principles
have no value or they're completely
wrong
but maybe we just need a more sort of
modern
view of them and maybe we can simplify
them a bit
now
looking at this slide from his talk
it's an example of something kevin likes
doing just about every talk he does
takes a picture of some of his books
usually on a floor or some other surface
and i quite like this idea
and as it happened
on the same day at the same conference i
was giving a talk in another room
and i said
what kevin does about about these books
i like the idea
problem is i don't actually read
physical books anymore so i took a photo
of my ipad
on the floor
now the reason i'm throwing this in is
because that talk
was about simplicity
as it happens
which as dan norford already said uh you
know he thinks that's really
the central theme to the solid
principles uh coincidence we're just
talking about the same thing
in the same room on the same day
we'll come back to how simplicity ties
this all together a bit later but uh
just to set you up there
okay
so
what really are then the problems with
the solid principles i've
hinted at some of them already but let's
just actually call them out so
a whole set of
criticisms that have been levelled at
the solid principles we're going to pick
these off and and see whether they apply
um
they're not actually principles with one
of kevin's points actually
not excessively named there's these
internal redundancies um
you know as that graph showed
you actually divide up into really two
two principles
uh maybe some of them are outdated like
the open close principle
or maybe their language or oo specific
well let's take that first one first
are they even principles
this is one of the questions kevin asked
and he
i think he quoted from the the oxford
english dictionary for the definition of
what a principle is i pulled up this
quote from the cambridge dictionary it
says very very similar
there's a reason i've chosen cambridge
i'll come to in a minute but
it says it's a basic truth that explains
or controls how something happens or
works
or a basic idea or rule
that explains or controls again how
something happens or works
or a moral rule
or standard of good behavior
fair dealing and calvin says well
these are not truths they're not rules
and there's nothing moral about them so
why why why do we call them principles
and you can sort of see where he's going
but
if you read on in the cambridge
dictionary
there's a little aside about in
principle
where it says if you agree with or
believe something in principle
you agree with the idea in general
although you may not support it in
reality in every situation
that actually sounds a lot closer
to the meaning that we think of when we
think of the solid principles yeah
they're good like guiding principles
but they don't necessarily apply in
every situation you've got to use your
own
thinking there so
i actually disagree with kevin on this
one i think that we're okay to call them
principles
in fact
in that article getting a solid start
bob martin
he has a section what do i mean by
principle
and he says society principles are not
rules
they're not laws
and they're not perfect truths
they're statements on the order of an
apple a day keeps the doctor away it's a
good principle it's good advice
but it's not a pure truth nor is it a
rule someone says if he read that
dictionary definition and said no that's
not what i mean i'm in this bit
and given is actually there in a
dictionary
i'm happy with that i don't think
anyone's really been misled
by the use of the word principle here so
um i'm happy to take that one off
but i'm not going to let him off the
hook quite so easily
because
he actually continues in that same
article
the principles are mental cubbyholes
they give a name to a concept so you can
talk and reason about that concept
so
if the reason for introducing the
principles is to give a name to it
did it actually do a good job of that
which leads us on to the next problem
that they're not excessively named by
that i mean
looking at those names
do you immediately know exactly what
you're actually trying to do with them
i think we've already hinted that that
there's some problems there
looking at the the single responsibility
principle well dan north called it the
pointlessly vague principle it's hard to
do something with that you sort of
intuitively know what we're getting at
but
you know what's the action required
there uh you need to dig a bit more and
know about cohesion and how that applies
to code
the open closed
principle problematic as well it's
simple enough to say you know open for
extension close for modification again
what does that really mean should we
really be
you know stopping things from being
modified
we already said maybe that was rooted in
the 80s and we can move on from that
has a slightly different meaning
and even the open to extension
bob martin's interpretation was
extension through
inheritance
and class hierarchies which is maybe
we're sort of moving away from as a unit
of reuse these days uh but actually if
you go back to bertrand may he was
talking about um functions and modules
as well
so
the idea of being able to extend things
is a bit more general than what's been
captured in the solid principles
and it's very difficult to get all of
that nuance just just from the name
which is why
most people go and think yeah i know
what that is and then they basically
forget
the disc of substitution principle
well it's based on somebody's name which
is not that helpful
okay it has the word substitution in
there
so something could do with
substitutability
but
really the meat of it is in the bit
that's not there in the name it's again
it's about those contracts and
how it relates to to behavior
you do need to dig quite a bit more to
really get to that meaning
interface segregation principle it's
fine
if it's useful as a principle but maybe
it's just it's a bit grand sounding for
something that's actually quite a simple
derivation of one of the other
principles but there you go
similar with the dependency inversion
principle
um
it almost obfuscates
the actual simple meaning behind it yeah
we can get there in the end but
i'm not sure this is actually that
helpful in understanding it in fact
there's an even bigger problem with this
one
maybe best illustrated with this
uh anyone know what this is
i'm not sure i'd
hear you in this room with everyone's
masks on so maybe i shouldn't get you to
call out but um
normally somebody eventually says upside
down glasses or something now you put
these on and you see the world upside
down
and
the purpose of these is like part of an
experiment
because the theory is that when we're
born we're not theory it's a fact
um
but when our eyes are wired to our our
brains upside down we
literally see the world upside down but
within a few days after we're born our
brain flips it and we go the rest of our
lives seeing things the right way up
until of course we put these glasses on
and then it flips it back again
but if you keep them on for a few days
and you know why would you unless you're
doing this experiment but
apparently it will flip again
brain's an amazing thing but what's this
got to do with the dependency inversion
principle we've got the word inversion
in there
and the point of this is to
you know point out this it's context
dependent what are we inverting with
you know relation to
um are we now seeing the world the right
way up or upside down
depends what came before so dependency
inversion principle
was sort of sort of about inverting what
we used to do with our dependencies
and we used to
you know depend on concrete uh
implementations and you know we depend
on interfaces so that the lines are
going the opposite direction they're
inverted compared to what we did before
but
now
most people
do things that way so if you're going to
invert it you're actually going to go
back to what we did before
so it's a bit problematic a bit
problematic but
yeah i think there are some problems
with the naming i definitely agree with
him on that
let's have a look at those internal
redundancies well we already saw this
this graph
um
it's uh it's definitely
definitely true that you can simplify
this down to
two maybe three key points with some
little nuances
uh or go as far as dan north and say
everything is just about writing simple
code but even if you try to stick to the
to the main message or the solid
principles
there's a bit too much repetition there
i'm not sure this is a terrible thing
it can be good to state things in
different ways and think about things in
slightly different ways
there's no guarantee these are all
orthogonal
so i think the overlapping part is fine
but
um
it's also useful to
dig into the underlying
ideas
and make sure that they are being
captured in our code
so yeah i'm not going to talk so much
about that
what about the fact that maybe some of
them are outdated
uh
we already looked at ocp
that the close for modification part um
i think we we can agree that that's not
really the spirit of agile these days
um and dependency injector
independency inversion again
is
it's outdated in the sense that we've
moved on from what we're inverting we
don't want to go back to that
so
a little bit but
most of the concepts are pretty timeless
so
i'm not as worried about this part as
some of the other problems
uh we do have that extra
part to ocp about not publishing
prematurely and i think that that still
holds even if we don't really talk about
it anymore
uh
let's get that
okay what about
the criticism that solid principles are
language specific
they're originally formulated in the
context of c plus plus
but
these days are probably most often
talked about in the context of something
like java
what about dynamic languages
uh can you apply lsp to a dynamic
language well when you know that it's
really about contracts then yes
absolutely you can even if you don't
necessarily have interfaces in the
language um
you definitely still need to respect the
contract of something if something
walks like a duck and quacks like a duck
um and a base contracts like a duck
then then only then is it a duck
um
and the dependency
inversion principle
originally was talking more about the c
c and c plus plus inclusion model
uh which made that really tricky to work
i mean i still work with safe plus plus
regularly it's still a big problem
um
but other languages have
mostly solved that in
a language level it's um not such a big
problem to keep those dependencies
inverted if you like
i still have to think about it but maybe
it's not such a core principle anymore
maybe that's why
it's easy to think about dependency
injection instead
uh and again um
the interface
segregation principle
uh what i've put here interfaces less
using c plus plus
uh because i think i originally
presented this to a c plus plus audience
but
interfaces as a main unit are also being
questioned these days
often
packaging things up in different ways
can be better but
that one's a bit more of a stretch but
it definitely needs to be to be looked
at i think
oh got some extra yeah we covered that
okay
what about
oh drop to the right now what about
the oo specific
i think this one has more merit but
actually when you look into it
maybe less so
so i've put the
isp dip maybe less relevant to a
functional language
although
i think the first time i gave this talk
i got a little bit of pushback on that
and
somebody said that
dependency
inversion principle is actually still
very very useful in a functional
language
ocp
still applies maybe to a data model in a
functional language
srp definitely still applies to to
functions
and
same with with lsp
uh substitutable types
if you're working with a functional
language all of these things really
still apply even if
you maybe don't have to work quite so
hard to get them because they're sort of
baked into the
link oh dear
okay
maybe i said functional language too
much
um
okay
i meant to take this slide out first
time i did this talk was at the acc
conference i had a 90 minute talk so i
had like a little section in the middle
where we could actually discuss things
but uh we're gonna we're gonna move on
and
get to
the second section
solid revisited revisited so having
presented
particularly kevin henny and dan north
criticisms of solid and
addressed some of them
um i want to present my own views on the
matter
but before we get to that
i mentioned some of the other
acronyms sets of principles that have
been proposed kevin henry's fluid
principles
i don't actually find the liquid
principles as well
obviously plays on this idea of states
of matter
hence the second part of my my title
we could definitely say those aren't dry
but uh
i'll leave that one there
kevlin's fluid principles and he did
this as a lightning talk again i don't
think it was intended to be entirely
serious but when i spoke to my xtc he
said no no no i didn't actually mean
them seriously
you decide
so he says
your code should be functional i
tend to agree with him there and the
screen hasn't flickered so that's good
um
should be loosely coupled
which sort of gets at the single
responsibility principle
unit testable
which i agree with but it's one of these
circular things because we're generally
applying these principles in order to
make our code more unit testable
and we do that by making it more unit
testable so it's a little bit
problematic but i think i'll see where
he's going
introspective
it's an interesting one
i think it's quite a powerful
technique that we're going to be seeing
more of in the future but i'm not quite
sure it qualifies as the principle at
least not yet it's more of a
an approach to to coding
adam potent i think it's definitely a
reach
uh trying to get that last letter in uh
he didn't even quite make that and i'm
not really sure how that applies but
um
what is interesting about this is
just the exercise of trying to come up
with a set of principles that you think
are meaningful and then fit an acronym
it was just a
useful exercise to do
um looking at the liquid principles
these are definitely meant to be the
joke
or a counter example
maybe your code should be large
long files and classes
with lots of interdependencies
breaking a single responsibility
principle a quagmire undocumented
illegible with plenty of duplicated code
so unfortunately i have seen many code
bases that follow the liquid principles
to the letter
i'm sure you have as well
all right well
one of the problems with with this
with a fluid in particular is it's not
really a state of matter it's sort of
two states
because it could be
a liquid or or gas
we didn't i didn't find anyone proposing
the gas principles
um
maybe code that relies too much on
getters and setters i don't know maybe
you can come up something better but
what about plasma
some promising letters there
maybe we'll do something with that but
actually if you if you dig enough
there's plenty of exotic states of
matter
that we could go with i pulled these all
off wikipedia i did try to get the bose
einstein condensate principles but um
i i gave up at some point
so let's go with plasma so here is my
attempt
the plasma principles
again it's really this exercise of you
know what can i actually fit into this
acronym not
intended to fully replace the solid
principles
um
let's have a look at these because i
think there's something in this
so persistence
what do i mean by this
so i don't mean
keep trying you'll get there in the end
and i don't mean you know writing to
files and databases
really talk about persistent data
structures
and i've done talks on on this
um just just very quickly to summarize
if you've got a like a
a tree structure like this
a binary tree
could be a red black tree
if you want to add something like that a
yellow node at the bottom there
if you copy all of the
the nodes up to the root
and put it on your your copy
i have links back into the original tree
the original tree persists it's still
there and you have a new tree which has
lots of shared states along with it
that's an example of a persistent data
structure if you haven't come across
that before
does this really make a principle though
well it's more of a proxy for
immutability because this is a great
technique for using more immutability in
your code while also
giving you you know rich data structures
and
being able to add things to them which
is particularly important with data
structures
so stand in for that so mutability i
think is
a principle worth striving for
local reasoning is the next one
so i'm going to
use a slide from
another talk i did um functional safe
plus plus for fun and profit i think i
should do it at this conference a few
years ago
just to illustrate
so this is safe plus code but it's
it's pretty universal so
uh shouldn't be a problem
so
typical
bit of code where you've you've got a
variable in this case color
and you want to give it a value based on
some condition in this case calling this
uh this function
seems simple enough
but there's a few problems packed in
there just a few lines of
um easy code
because
we need to make that call in order to
know
what we're going to assign to it we
can't use an initialization here which
means we've got an uninitialized
variable
and
maybe we would initialize it to some
default state and then change it but
that doesn't feel right either it
doesn't really reflect the intent
um and then it has to be mutable
we can't make it uh const
in the c plus plus keyword sense
so
it's mutable
and then we've got a side effect in the
if statement in order to make that
assignment
so there's a few things that we would
prefer not to to be there but the one i
want to particularly draw our attention
to is that mutability again
um so i know that's connected more to
the
my first principle but it's so important
mentioning again
the consequence of that
is
fine for maybe these few lines of code
but now
that um that variable its value
is entangled with all the rest of the
code to go through
in order to reason
about the value of color you have to
look at every line of code it may pass
through
because something else may change it
because we couldn't make it const we've
lost that guarantee
so we've lost the ability to reason
about it locally and it might not seem
an important thing
these things really add up we sort of
uh think of it as the cost of doing
business we're so used to just losing
track of values and what they what state
they may be in because of the default
mutability in most of the languages we
work in
that we don't even think about local
reasoning most of the time
but when you can get that back
and this is why it's uh
you'll often hear functional programmers
talk about local reasoning because they
do have those guarantees
it's really hard to to give that up
again so
that's why i
put it as its own
principle
um
yeah so did they propose if c plus plus
was more like a functional language you
could do something like this where you
treat the if statement as an expression
um of course you can use a ternary
operator in this case uh most languages
have that as well but it doesn't scale
very well
and the other talk i've done i've shown
how you can fake it by using
an immediately invoked lambda expression
so you wrap the statements up in a
lambda immediately invoke it and it
effectively converts it into an
expression really useful technique for
getting back
local reasoning
okay
algorithms next
and again maybe this is a bit more of a
a c plus plus bias um at least
my example here uh
sean perrin
did a talk uh some years ago c plus plus
seasonings
where he's talking about suplex plus
algorithms
uh the main message is no raw loops so
if you find yourself writing a loop out
by hand
think about if there's
again if it's c plus plus an algorithm
uh whatever language you're using will
have
algorithms or something similar
in the standard library hopefully
um
point is like those little loops even if
they may seem simple they're they're
just packed full of complexity that
can come back to bite us
um
do something that somebody else is
actually optimized and thought through
and got got right
instead
and then we come to simplicity
so i said we'll come back to this this
was dan north's uh main idea and i tend
to agree with him in fact i've done a
whole talk
on simplicity
uh the one that i
was giving in nbc london same time as
kevin
actually that talk was mostly a riff off
another talk by rich hickey simple made
easy
anyone seen simple made easy
a couple of hands
you should definitely watch that talk
again references at the end
but i do reference a lot of it
in my talk
in particular this slide these
illustrations i i stole from rich hickey
as i think they they really illustrate
it uh quite nicely
so what rich did and i
in my talk as well
let's go back to the latin roots of the
english words simple and complex
so a complex in latin
means something with many folds or
braids
whereas a simplex where we get the
modern english word simple from
meant something with one fold or braid
so
simply enough meanings makes sense and
you can sort of see how they actually
carry the meaning
uh forward looking at the illustrations
if you look at the the one on the left
the simple case
if you try to follow one of those
strands
from the bottom to the top
well it's trivial you don't even have to
think about it you know exactly where it
ends up
but try doing that with the complex case
on the right
follow one of the strength you've got to
carefully follow it all the way up
and there's only four strands there
complexity
makes us lose track of things very very
quickly
and yet our code
tends to be full of it
with this definition of complexity you
can think about all the things in
typical code that
cause complexity very often not
necessarily
threading currency is an obvious one and
maybe we need it but
hopefully we can find ways to protect
ourselves from it
globals or singletons
if we had those in our code
they
basically bring different parts of the
code together
as a codependency
um often in very hidden ways
any other sort of shared state similarly
mutability
coming back to that one again
already
talked about immutability earlier again
because
it uh complicates
the value of something and and passage
of time
as it evolves so it's uh
another hidden complexity that uh we're
sort of not used to to thinking about
maybe
cyclomatic complexity but it's got
complexity in the name but it's really
overuse of conditionals and branches
leaky abstractions is an interesting one
now i um
we'll actually come back to instructions
in a bit
so i have another section from
my simplicity talk that i'm going to
revisit
code and module dependencies we'll talk
a bit less about should be fairly
obvious and
that's definitely captured in the um in
the solid principles
so yeah let's fast forward onto
obstructions we'll skip over modularity
for a moment
so this is a slide from my simplicity
talk it's actually a quote from joel
spolsky
you may recognize all non-trivial
abstractions
to some degree are leaky
i grade some words out because i think
the statement is stronger if you take
those words out and i think it's still
accurate
and i attempted to prove this in my in
my other talk where i actually talked
about
um for example the evolution of our
number theory
over the millennia
how often that abstraction just of
numbers that we rely on every day has
been leaky at different points in time
so if we can't get that right you know
what hope do we have of the code that
we're writing in a week
so yeah all abstractions are leaky
but they're also
probably our biggest weapon in the fight
against complexity
so it's a real dilemma this this
double-edged sword
so i'll go into some ideas in that talk
about how to deal with it but it
basically amounts to
give up on these all-encompassing
metaphors for your abstractions
um unless you are going for
something like you know building a
language or a standard library or
something that you're going to invest
the time in making it watertight as
possible i've always embraced the
leakiness it's going to leak anyway
so try not to make that
too much of a complicating factor when
you have to deal with it
so
be careful with your obstructions
so you've probably seen this quote
uh george box all models are wrong but
some are useful
similarly all abstractions are leaking
but some are useful
oh and here's the slide
where i talk about uh
what i call global abstractions that's
those
languages standard libraries things are
going to invest the effort in to make as
complete and watertight as possible
or local abstractions the things you can
have in your own code
let's say brace the leakiness try to
keep those objections shallow
do you ever have the experience of like
debugging through some code and you're
about like 10 abstractions down
trying to work out what you're actually
dealing with here is you know is it this
thing at this level
those objections are just complicating
things at that point so
we need them
as an organizational unit to manage that
complexity but we just got to be careful
try to make them shallow and embrace the
leakiness
okay
modularity
i don't have that much to say about it i
mostly threw it in because i just needed
that other letter it sort of fits with a
single responsibility principle
but
no great insights there
but that
is the the plasma principles
um maybe you want to
try your own exercise of coming up with
a set of principles that
you think are important and see how your
encode holds up to them
but
that's been
solid
revisited there is the
url for where all the references to all
of the other materials my talks the
other talks i've talked about
and articles
levitarian direction dot com
slash refs slash solid.html
if you can't remember that i also have
extra level of indirection.com that
redirects there
so
that's the end of the talk
thank you very much do we have any
questions
do we share the means to
ask questions
mike or
no
i don't really wanna
call out i can't see everyone from here
okay
last time i did this talk i went a bit
over time so i may be rushed a little
bit too much this time
okay
well in that case thank you very much
[Applause]
you